[Musique]
pis pleurais je me souviendrai toujours
de pitray disait que ce groupe durerait
deux semaines ce point mais ça nous a
bien démoralisés
[Musique]
ça
oh
audacieux et sans peur parfois trop
ambitieux l'énigmatique groupe pink
floyd à repousser les frontières de la
musique jusqu'à de nouveaux domaines
d'expression artistique
[Musique]
leur carrière en studio a commencé à
l'époque de la télévision en noir et
blanc et s'est achevée en plein âge de
l'internet
ce sont des légendes vivantes pas
seulement des légendes ils sont comme le
prologue et les pilotes d'un livre
en
ils ont commencé par provoquer une
explosion dans le mouvement de cité sur
ils sont devenus le plus grand de tous
les groupes d'arena rock qui est ensuite
devenu une véritable icône
un jour on est passé prendre si des il
était complètement maquiller n'ont pas
tout à fait comme une drag queen mais
pas loin
blanc et on a tous décidé de faire comme
si de rien n'était
[Musique]
on
et fait absolument aucun doute que s'il
était schizophrène et qu'il consommait
de la drogue en même temps on a soi-même
la responsabilité de la quantité
comprend bien sûr je ne veux pas faire
de peine à ses frères ses soeurs ses
oncles et tantes et à tous ceux qu'il
aimait mais à une époque il s'était
caché derrière la porte de son
appartement brandissant sa guitare pour
essayer la somme et sa copine il faut
les assumer l'insee avec lui j'ai
prévenu sa famille de son état pour
qu'ils s'occupent de lui mais il son
pari
[Musique]
je me souviens bien du soulagement
ressenti lorsque si des parties
oui nul on savait que le public
continuerait à nous demander si c'est
effectivement ça a duré 30 minutes
[Musique]
en surmontant la perte de six barrettes
pink floyd avait peu d'identité public
en dehors de ses albums leur manque de
charisme et d'esprit rock'n'roll leur a
néanmoins valu de nombreux fans attiré
par la nature paradoxal de leur succès
il avait parfois l'air assez diabolique
sortie est éclairé par en bas
et puis la drogue fait aussi cet effet
saout
il ya une chose qu'on ne pouvait pas ne
pas voir c'est qu'ils étaient tous
totalement désintéressée je me souvienne
rosel qui tournait le dos au public par
provocation
ils avaient tous l'air d'avoir acheté
leurs vêtements dans des friperies sac
[Musique]
ce que j'ai c'était horriblement
embarrassant point que je jouais le plus
souvent dos au public
j'étais extrêmement gênée et nerveux à
cause de ce que je faisais n'était pas
du tout sûr de moi je ne savais pas quoi
jouer tout poil
[Musique]
et ça
pink floyd a créé une musique rester
parmi les plus acclamés de tous les
temps ils ont vendu plus d'un milliard
d'albums et pourtant leurs querelles
publiques et amer ont parfois menacés
d'éclipsé leur accomplissement
artistique
le problème c'est qu'on était soit en
train de se battre soit de s'éclater
il n'y avait pas vraiment de juste
milieu nos problèmes personnels commencé
à nous dépasser de plus en plus sur nos
têtes
rogers est devenu une sorte de leader
m et moi n'étions pas du tout sur la
même longueur d'onde à l'époque il avait
son idée à lui de ce qu'on allait faire
et moi j'avais une toute autre image et
j'ai été ravi que ce soit mon idée qui
finissent par l'emporter
[Musique]
dave et nick sont allés voir rogers et
lyon dit on peut faire une tournée avec
pink floyd en groupe et rogers a répondu
vous ne pouvez pas faire une tournée
sans moi pink floyd c'est moi et eux
sont dit pourtant il n'ya pas beaucoup
de chansons de rogers dans le spectacle
pour rester poli
[Musique]
désolé mais le groupe ne s'est jamais
appris à rogers et les all-stars ç'a
toujours été pink floyd
[Musique]
c'est l'histoire classique quand les
avocats conseillent à leurs clients
disputé vous mais ne mettez rien par
écrit ils ont sûrement en tête la lettre
que rogers waters a écrit pour quitter
pink floyd c'est un argument infaillible
[Musique]
et
il faut faire une thérapie pour se
remettre d'avoir été un membre du groupe
[Musique]
pink floyd est née de deux groupes
d'amis communs cette barrette et roger
waters se sont connus à cambridge
nick eric besnard à la différence des
stones des beatles n'étaient pas issus
des classes ouvrières vivent et tous
dans un environnement assez aisée
malheureusement j'étais au lycée avec
laure jawad c'était une école étrange
une école pour garçons et premiers
souvenirs avec lui remonte à cette
époque je crois c'était un lycée plutôt
difficile qu'on peut dire que c'était un
lycée d'enseignement général
mais il y avait quelques gamins comme
rogers est loin il s'étirait pas bien
dans cette école qui était plutôt pour
la bourgeoisie
tous les deux on était là pour fumer en
cachette derrière le garage à vélos et
faire des bêtises à la moindre occasion
rodgeur rodgeur faisait ça il était
assez impressionnant
maintenant elle est bon mais à l'époque
il avait une tête bizarre très allongée
mais il a vraiment bien vieilli au
cambridge high school de garçons on
trouvait aussi roger qu'ils barrette
ils étaient deux classes en dessous de
moi à l'école on s'est rapproché à
l'adolescence images on faisait tout
semblant de s'intéresser à leur intime
que qui allen ginsberg et on parlait
fumer des joints sans jamais le faire
c'est à peu près en 1959 que j'ai
rencontré signe pour la première fois à
l'époque il s'appelait encore roger
barrett qu'on allait faire de la barque
ou pique-niqué ça bien sûr c'était avant
qu'on se met à fumer des joints et une
fois qu'on s'y est mis on était
absolument ravi les premiers souvenirs
de cible ce sont ceux d'un garçon
pétillant imposant al'allure princière
vais quand même pu vous le dire c'était
un très beau garçon
on savait qu il était poète artiste
peintre et qu'il commençait à jouer de
la guitare
cambridge comme la plupart des villes
britanniques à l'époque était le théâtre
d'une scène musicale florissante
[Musique]
on allait souvent chez sa mère sur les
fraudes
le samedi après midi et ont joué la
musique
je me souviens que je me posais avec lui
à cambridge pour jouer de la guitare
acoustique
j'étais là quand on joue et ice road
ce qui est intéressant c'est que le vrai
nom de sid
what else
il s'appelait tous les deux auteurs et
ils avaient tous les deux perdu leur
père je crois que c'est ça qui les a
vraiment beaucoup rapprochés par le même
ben c'est toi je me souviens du jour
aussi d'étaler acheter une futurama 3
c'est une terre rouge en espèces de
plastique avant ont bidouillé avec des
guitares acoustiques et je me souviens
en particulier de cils apprenant à jouer
à page
[Musique]
syd barrett créateur légendaire du son
de pink floyd allait devenir l'un des
rockers les plus mythiques de l'histoire
[Musique]
on y parle je trouve aussi très
impressionnant
il avait quelque chose de presque
féerique il faisait tourner les têtes
même à 14 15 ans fifteen il était une
sorte de figure charismatique les gens
le remarquent et parler de lui quick
il avait cette sorte de magnétisme
[Musique]
je me suis dit c'est magnifique
il est tellement beau il ressemblait à
l'archétype du poète maudit
il avait deux magnifiques yeux violet
des cheveux noirs en bataille ils
étaient très minces
il avait un look très intéressant et il
ne parlait pas beaucoup ma mission
c'était d'apaiser sa fièvre ses
angoisses
ce n'est que tard que j'ai réussi à me
retrouver seule avec lui et à me faire
remarquer de façon plus intime
[Musique]
il était comme ça ils illuminé la scène
aussi et je suis convaincu que la
plupart des gens y compris moi maestri
éprouvait une certaine jalousie envers
cette luminosité qui l'habitait
[Musique]
je ne sais pas pourquoi mais on a
toujours eu cette intuition qu'en
partant à londres qui était la mecque de
la musique on formerait un groupe tous
ensemble star band cas
[Musique]
à
l'année 1966 marque l'émergence d'une
nouvelle scène underground
après deux décennies d'austérité d'après
guerre l'économie est en plein boom et
l'idéalisme et l'optimisme sont monnaies
courantes landré désormais envahies de
ses stands où l'on peut dénicher une
collection appelée le supermarché de
l'entité est ici ces antiquités peuvent
être des vêtements cette dame à régler
sa machine à remonter le temps sur les
années 20 et leurs moeurs délurée pas
sûr que ce soit une destination
recherchée par beaucoup de voyageurs
dans le temps l'un des moyens pour
refuser l'autorité c'est de la parodie
certains de ces jeunes qui disent
rarement où il ya grand chose yann à
sceaux où bat le coeur de londres et où
les jeunes filles viennent dans des
clubs voir des hommes se dévêtir ou
serait ce la verse
ici chacun peut adopter un uniforme du
passé afin d'affronter l'uniformité du
présent c'était pâques c'était debitel
sergent pepper all you need is love
on était au coeur de tout ça c'était
extraordinaire et très excitant cette
période des années 60 a vraiment été une
époque particulière aux capteurs ne l'y
a eu l'année entre l'été 1966 et l'été
1976 qui a vraiment été une période
fantastique très fertile est extrêmement
active actuelle
ce lieu appelé the works and la fin du
monde marque en fait la fin de king's
road
ce qui montre bien ce que les gens
disent y pense de mère mamie part en
voyage c'est le nom de la boutique que
cache le visage si typique de l'atypique
se conformant à l'image anticonformiste
de la tendance
ce qui avait le vent en poupe ou qui
étaient dans le coup in ou encore dans
le vent ce que mamie justement appelé la
toute dernière tendance mon chéri
il existe une image très idéalisée des
années 60 elle est en partie justifiée
mais pas entièrement
on imagine le milieu des années 60 on
est tenté d'imaginer une culture de
drogués n'ont juste pas seulement sexe
drogue et rock'n'roll mais vraiment tout
le monde sous lsd et du sexe tout le
temps vous allez être drôlement épuisant
tout ça si c'est vrai mais bien
évidemment ce n'était pas ça
roger waters week wright et nick mason
se rencontrent en première année
d'architecturé à londres nick mason et
roger waters étaient tous les deux à
regent street polytechnique
comme beaucoup de jeunes gens ils ont eu
envie de monter un groupe
pendant une période c'était presque un
groupe de l'école toutes les répétitions
avaient lieu à la fac ils ont eu
différentes identités et différemment ce
sont appelés les screaming aktas sigma 6
le 17
megadeth vous avez quelques autres
garçons dans le groupe kiss novel mais
climate calf faisait partie du groupe au
début je pense que le vrai début c'était
avec 6 des bobs et puis rogers et moi
certains d'entre eux s'était installée à
londres
vous avez aussi un appartement stand up
gardens et s'il a fini par arriver aussi
pendant ce temps qu'il arrive j'avais
déjà commencé à jouer avec quelques
autres personnes donc et c'est joan où
il vivait avec toute une communauté de
personnes comme timothy leary croyez
vraiment que là si tu pouvais les
délivrer et les mener à la vérité
[Musique]
il vivait aux 101 cromwell road c'était
tout simplement le royaume de l'acide
les gens métier dans le thé des autres
sans rien leur dire c'était vraiment
trop personnellement j'aimais être au
courant quand je prenais de l'acide
on a vécu au sacre - drones avec site
pendant un moment on était cinq ou six
et j'étais la seule femme david décrit
le sens comme un endroit tendance où les
grands esprits se retrouver pour passer
du bon temps des américains comme allen
ginsberg des sons comme mick jagger
marianne faithfull fidji produits et les
pink floyd et début c'était la fête tous
les soirs
tout le monde est en plein trip la
maison était pleine de femmes superbes
oui on prenait du lsd on se teignait le
visage c'était complètement fou le nst
le diéthylamide de l'acide lysergique
est entré dans nos vies et je vais vous
dire c'était légal ligue au toit branche
toi extrait toile le message est simple
il tient en six mots fleixois ouvre toi
bonsoir extrait toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
écrire se brancher s'extrait c'est ce
qui arrive quand on prend une dose de
cette nouvelle drogue étrange appelé l
est et le lsd devenu un mode de vie avec
ses propres philosophes comme le poète
allen ginsberg
il ya sans doute aux états unis de
millions de gens qui aimeraient sortir
matin par comme on le fait ici jouent
avec leurs enfants et chanter ensemble
c'est étrange d'être dans un corps je
peux couché avec vous et si on chantait
ensemble mais je ne veux pas être
embarrassé je ne veux pas avoir à lutter
et je ne veux pas devoir lutter contre
moi-même constamment ni contre la caméra
c'est ça la communication les gens qui
vont voir ça que vont ils penser les
initiales lsv désigne le diéthylamide de
l'acide lysergique un dérivé chimique
issu d'un champignon se développant dans
le sel moins addictif que l'héroïne ou
la cocaïne
il a cependant des effets bien plus
puissant prix sous forme de cachets ou
sur un morceau de sucre
il agit en une heure et pendant 24
heures durant ce laps de temps on
s'élève dans un autre monde où la
conscience semble s'étendre à l'infini
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'expérience
psychédélique
le docteur timothy viry grand prêtre
américain du à lester et son fervent
défenseur l'a décrit ainsi d'ouvrir son
esprit se brancher sur l'infini
s'extraire du temps et de l'espace
mais il ya aussi un revers du lsd qui
fait débat le trip n'est pas toujours
agréable qui peut parfois être
bouleversant et même terrifiant le lsd
procure sans aucun doute une expérience
non interpersonnelles une expérience
artistique très intense mais je ne
dirais pas que c'est une drogue qui
élargit la conscience au contraire cette
drogue est aussi la conscience
cet incident a commencé à prendre goût à
cette expérience du lsd et c'est à cette
époque qu'on s'est intéressé au
mysticisme orientale sous le rsd on
expérimentait cet amour universel
cette merveilleuse ouverture des portes
de la perception et beaucoup d'entre
nous vous les trouvez ce sens
d'ouverture sans drogue
[Musique]
la moitié d'entre nous sommes devenus ce
qu'on appelle des 500 go pour suivre la
voie il fallait arrêter la drogue
l'alcool et devenir végétarien cidh a
demandé à entrer dans le groupe à être
initiés à cette forme de méditation
il est arrivé il a dit qu'il le ferait
qu'il arrêterait la drogue
je lui ai dit tu ne peux pas arrêter la
drogue qui en a besoin mais il est allé
voir le maître pour être initiés
[Musique]
sharon zynga refusé ça a été un coup dur
pour sid salle a pu verser
il s'est senti rejeté je pense que
sharon singh pouvait déjà voir que cet
homme n'était pas équilibrée et qu'un
voyage en inde n'était sans doute pas
une bonne idée mais jenny et moi on est
parti en inde pour suivre charles singh
[Musique]
si des leads et se sont installés dans
notre chambre et les choses ont dégénéré
[Musique]
quand on est rentré au sein comme red
road on a découvert quand notre absence
il y avait une soirée pour la
légalisation de la marijuana
ça avait attiré beaucoup d'attention et
là je me suis dit que l'âge d'or du sein
était peut-être passé
et puis rogers est arrivé un jour en
disant j'ai acheté une superbe voiture
américaine qui vont venir en grèce
je vais aller à patmos là où saint jean
a reçu la révélation bien sûr l'odeur tu
veux dire il ya des voitures donc avec
jenny rogers et judy sa petite amie eric
on s'est entassée dans la voiture qui
était évidemment rose et on est parti
pour pas tous on a pris le départ
et au milieu de la nuit on était sur
l'autoroute quelque part en allemagne
c'est eric qui conduisait on s'est
réveillé la voiture n'avançait plus
qu'en marche arrière
c'était la panne on a laissé la voiture
on a pris le train
caen s'est trouvé un petit bateau
jusqu'à patmos qu'on n'avait pas
beaucoup d'argent donc qui il a fallu
réduire les frais on s'est trouvé une
petite maison ensemble il me semble que
rogers et sa petite amie de l'époque du
dit on dormait à l'étagé sur un matelas
et nigel et moi et on a dormi dans la
cuisine une et bien sûr il y avait de la
drogue
c'est là que roger waters a eu son
premier trip à l'acide sur l'île de
patmos on regardait des représentations
de saint-jean le divan et il y avait un
rayon de soleil qui éclaire et le front
de rogers qui faisait comme un trou sur
son front on était dans un membre sacrés
il avait un rayon de soleil sur le front
je crois qu'il a trouvé ça très étrange
le genre de chose qui n'arrive qu'une
fois je lui ai demandé s'il aimerait
être célèbre et il m'a répondu ouais
et puis on est rentré à londres et c'est
là que tout a commencé
[Musique]
au fil de leur carrière leur musique est
devenue si sophistiqué qu'il est
difficile de voir pink floyd comme un
banal groupe de rythm and blues et
pourtant c'est bien comme ça qu'ils ont
commencé
au départ pink floyd était censé être un
groupe de blues blues mais la scène
blues avaient un peu décliné à ce
moment-là store et pour moi les pink
floyd n'ont jamais été de pure
fanatiques de blues comme d'autres
groupes l'ont été avec la drogue et tout
ça on était là c'est des chansons pop de
deux ou trois minutes
on voulait des choses plus long dans
lesquels s'immerger in-flight c'était
vraiment la première musique qui nous
faisait entrer dans une conscience ou
acide fond il pouvait jouer des riffs de
40 minutes sur un titre ça ne s'arrêtait
jamais c'est ça qu'on aime et on se
perdait dans la variété infinie des
solos 1966 non seulement les beatles
mais beaucoup d'autres groupes avaient
découvert affiche encore un bris tout ce
qui va avec le sitar des ragas un rat
gap duré une demi heure et ce sera que
l'introduction imaginer avait assisté à
un concert de leurs amis chanteurs au
festival donc je suppose que c'est là
qu'il a brisé son influence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a commencé par jouer du blues et je
crois qu'aucun d'entre nous en tout cas
pas moi ne savait vraiment à ce moment
là qui est le genre de groupe on allait
devenir au début puis clown a commencé
avec beaucoup de blues ou ce qu'on
appelle le rnb et puis ensuite a
commencé à en faire de plus longs
morceaux à mesure qu'il s'intéressait au
nouveau mouvement qui apparaissait à
l'époque on s'asseyait et s'il faisait à
dessein de la disposition d'équipements
pour savoir de quelle ampli on aurait
besoin tu réponds disait d'eux à ses 30
ans mais des voix et la guitare sur un
as et 30 et la basse le rythme et le
clavier sur l'autre il y avait toujours
un plombier brésil
le groupe commence par jouer leurs deux
concerts sur des scènes alternatives
[Musique]
ils ont réussi à avoir une place dans un
club de kensington rappelé le candidat
pour jouer 17 de 90 minutes trois fois
dans la soirée ils se sont rendu compte
qu'ils n'avaient pas assez de morceaux
donc ils se sont mis à rallonger ce
qu'ils avaient en improvisant c'est
ainsi que sont apparus les longs
instrumentaux planant de pink floyd
dans une sorte de cave à notting hill se
trouvait un endroit appelé all saints ce
rôle
les pink floyd show est là et quand on
arrivait et qu'on les entende et jouer
on se rendait compte que c'était
vraiment une musique futuriste pendant
longtemps ça a vraiment été la musique
du futur
[Musique]
ce que je me rappelle de ce concert
c'était le son le plus fort que j'ai
jamais entendu mes tympans ont résonné
pendant des heures et des heures après
dire que la plupart des morceaux qu'on
jouait était très mauvais mais je pense
que si on s'en est bien tiré sur
certains trucs c'est parce que tout le
public était sous l'effet de la drogue
ce type du melody maker chris welsh a
décrit leur musique comme un vacarme
assourdissant
il ne supportait pas les impôts c'était
un gros schizophrène en quelque sorte
[Musique]
pendant un bon moment commercialement il
s'est tu es mort je ne crois pas que les
compagnies de disques avait envie de les
connaître
seul le public non plus sans aucun doute
sas une crapule succès qu'ils ont eu
plus tard il est difficile de croire
qu'ils ont passé plusieurs années à
galérer
et
[Musique]
j'ai vu pink floyd pour la première fois
lors d'un concert caritatif dans un
local paroissial à notting hill gate et
en les entendant je me rappelle m'être
dit ouah c'est génial parce que c'était
le grand producteur de la scène
underground
je souhaitais un ancien patriote
américain et il était déjà un producteur
très respecté il avait pas mal d'influx
ans sur tout ce qui se passait dans les
années 60
[Musique]
à l'été 1966 pink floyd sont trouvés de
manager peter john a et en don king
je connaissais peter jenner et andrew
king et j'étais au sol qu'il connaissait
dans le milieu de la musique
ils m'ont donné un enregistrement du
groupe je me suis tout de suite tourné
vers elektra ouaki ce travail est encore
de ceux qui les engage le directeur de
lectra est venu en angleterre j'ai
organisé un show case hausse mais il ne
s'est pas intéressé et j'ai été renvoyé
je voulais vraiment rester en angleterre
je mets ça avait besoin d'une source de
revenus
ouais je devais payer mon loyer j'ai
donc commencé en est des gens ajouté
pink floyd il n'y avait pas besoin
d'être un génie pour se rendre compte
que sid écrivait des chansons
extraordinaire et que c'était un groupe
très intéressant que joe boys se trouve
une nouvelle vocation et ouvre le
premier club de rock psychédélique
en angleterre on a inauguré lui faut
club le 23 décembre 1966 avec un concert
des pink floyd
tant qu'on ne sait pas vraiment qui
serait là la seule pub qu'on avait fait
c'était un petit encart dans melody
maker et dans l'internationale times et
on avait distribué des flyers sur
portobello road le samedi précédent on
était très tendue parce qu'on avait payé
15 livres je crois pour louer une salle
pour le vendredi soir il faisait un
temps glacial
et on ne savait pas qui allait venir
même pas finalement la salle était
pleine et le public était composé de
gens que je pourrais appeler des tarifs
au jazz freaks
[Musique]
il fait ici il faut claude était un
endroit un peu miteux il n'y avait pas
de place pour s'asseoir tout le monde
était allongé par sou à regarder la
scène où l'écran en fait c'était juste
un endroit où aller pour planer sous
acide
certains certains étaient réellement
stupéfait de voir qu'il y avait autant
d'autres personnes comme eux ils
arrivaient et se disait en fait on n'est
pas seul mon groupe d'amis et moi ne
sommes pas les seuls à porter des
vêtements fut consommé des substances
étrange et à vouloir écouter ce genre de
musique
donc ça a été une sorte de révélation
pour moi ainsi que pour le public de
voir que ça intéressait autant de gens
ce qu'on appelle aussi l' orchestre de
chambre ne regarde le vendredi soir il
joue à l'ufo club avec d'autres groupes
du faux ovni objet volant non identifié
une atmosphère nocturne ou des
projections de films et des conserves
font de ce night club underground un
grand lieu de divertissement
le reste de la semaine étonnamment qu'il
s'agit d'une salle de danse irlandaise
c'est ici que le mouvement de grogne
s'expose à la culture jeune
les seules personnes âgées de plus de 30
ans sont des journalistes venus observer
ce qui s'y passe elles sont traitées
avec une tolérance amusé de la part des
personnes qu'ils observent l'un des
objectif ici est de faire de la musique
une expérience sensorielle de fusionner
et faire exploser chaque son chaque
lumière au plus profond des spectateurs
il s'agit d'une expérience mystique et
d'élite comme on l'appelle au mode une
expansion de l'esprit psychédélique est
un terreau même sur des employés par les
commentateurs comme mot valise pour
désigner tout ce qu'ils ne comprennent
pas complètement
si cette musique alors le psychédélisme
risque bien de nous accompagner pendant
longtemps beaucoup le considèrent comme
la musique populaire de demain une
expérience plus qu'une mélodie
un registre je prenais l'acide à
l'époque par terre pendant qu'il jouait
je sortais de mon corps au son de leur
musique
j'ai été transporté à des centaines des
milliers d'années lumière dans le cosmos
heureusement sans même que sam raimi
il emmenait ses superbes morceaux avec
de longues improvisations il les jouets
devant des lumières bondissante aux
couleurs variées parme ce genre de
choses c'est génial parce que ça
renforçait toute cette expérience et je
n'étais pas le seul à ressentir ça tout
le monde le sentais vraiment tout le
monde
c'était incroyable
c'était très obscur très étrange et
l'effet global et et hypnotisant étaient
vêtus de satin et de soi lumière les
faisait briller ils ressemblaient à des
sortes de grandes gargouilles de couleur
à londres le mouvement underground est
encore petit mais ailleurs il est devenu
une grande force des terres de
l'éphémère les concerts improvisés des
spectacles son et lumière se multiplient
et la musique psychédélique gagne du
terrain
underground d'aujourd'hui sera peut-être
une réponse à l'austérité de demain
oui mais on nous appelait les beautiful
people mais le news of the world qui
avait entendu parler de nous et était
venu voir ce qui se passait a répondu la
nouvelle que certaines personnes faisait
tourner des pétards comme si on n'en
avait jamais eu s'est enfin bref le
monde extérieur commencé à avoir un
aperçu de ce qui se passait dans ce
qu'on appelait l'un d'eux grade
[Musique]
d
je ne
agence e rédacteur du news of the world
m'a demandé si j'avais des photos des
pink floyd et j'ai répondu non
donc je me suis arrangée avec peter
jenner leur manager de l'époque qui m'a
dit que oui bien sûr venez prendre des
photos j'ai eu un peu peur quand il m'a
dit avant je ne l'accepté aucune
nourriture aucune boisson plus
cigarettes
rien ne venait pas demander pourquoi
j'ai juste acquiescé j'y suis allé et
tout le monde était adorable proposer
une tasse de thé j'ai dit non terroriser
une sémaphore il avait l'air de quatre
garçons très bien élevé c'est plutôt
bourgeois à flixecourt les avait un air
naturellement perplexe je crois que
c'est le bon mot berbère
[Musique]
je pense qu'il ne comprenait pas
pourquoi je leur demandais de prendre
leurs instruments de les déplacer
qui sait regarder l'air un peu moqueur
il devait se demander qu'est-ce qu'il
veut cette folle j'ai dû y retourner
parce que la première fois ils avaient
tous l'air de planer un peu jenner m'a
dit qu'ils préfèreraient refaire une
séance photo un jour ou si barrès aurait
moins l'air à l'ouest
cette berline boxer best et lors de la
deuxième séance ils ont pris le contrôle
ils ont suivi les directives de jenner
la pucelle
[Musique]
mais le news of the world à utiliser les
photos pour un sujet sur la drogue
je ne savais pas que c'était pour ça je
me suis dit zut je vais me prendre un
processus il est difficile de dire
qu'ils étaient drogués et qui ne l'était
pas dans le premier mois ça devait être
un bon pourcentage mais ensuite la pub
attirer vos goûts de personnes
extérieures qui avaient peu d'expérience
en matière de drogue
en plus la police a commencé à
s'intéresser à nous et ils procédaient à
des fouilles dans la file d'attenté
devant le club
plus il y avait de monde - il y avait de
drôles
[Musique]
la priorité numéro un du groupe c'est de
sortir un album en janvier 1967
joe boy oriente les pink floyd vers un
studio à chelsea afin d'enregistrer une
chanson écrite par barrett arnold layne
c'était un plaisir de travailler avec
eux on s'est beaucoup amusés à
enregistrer arnold layne et sa face b
on l'a enregistré en une soirée et mixez
le soir suivant
ça n'a pas été une opération très longue
mais on s'est bien amusé enfin elle est
arrivée dans lé 20e au hit parade
elle a été interdite sur radio londres
parce qu'elle encourageait le
travestissement ou je ne sais quoi ça
parle d'un type qui renifle et culottes
des filles dans son jardin c'est un peu
coquin et on était en 1967 à la bbc il
commençait tout juste à l'utiliser de la
musique pop et d'un coup on leur
présentait une chanson qui parle d'un
type un peu pervers dont ils ont réagi
en interdisant ce qui évidemment a fait
une pub énorme
je pense que la chance on aurait pu
monter plus haut ils paradent si elle
n'avait pas été interdite
mais on peut aussi se dire qu'elle est
entrée au hit-parade justement parce
qu'elle a été interdite
on ne saura jamais oh non
une maison de disques qui émaillent est
suffisamment impressionné pour signer
pink floyd à la condition qu'ils
acceptent de travailler en exclusivité
avec les producteurs du label dans leur
studio de abbey road
joe boyd est alors renvoyé sans
cérémonie
peter jenner et andrew king ont réussi à
s'arranger avec emma ils ont signé pour
[Musique]
je n'ai pas été vexé qu'il signe chez ea
emai
même si évidemment ça ne m'a pas fait
plaisir qu'il ne signait pas avec ma
compagnie chez polydor mais là où j'ai
été vraiment déçu c'est caen qui
émaillent a dit non pas question
d'employer joe boyd
on va travailler avec notre propre
producteur là ça ne m'a pas plus qu'aux
jo était parfait pour nous et il a
produit deux singles vraiment excellent
cinq gosses mais après tout a changé
ouais le groupe commence
l'enregistrement de leur premier album
piper at the gates of dawn au studio 3
d'abbey road
au même moment dans le studio 2 les
beatles travaillent sur ces jeunes
pepper's lonely hearts club band
ce qui était bien chez ea et mike holmes
maison de disques
c'est qu'on s'était arrangé dans les
clauses du contrat pour avoir un accès
illimité au studio tout studio on y
passait donc beaucoup de temps on a
appris beaucoup de choses
en grande partie grâce aux beatles ont
travaillé sur piper at the gates of dawn
dans les studios d'abbey road et dans le
studio d'à côté les beatles enregistrent
est sergent pepper il se rendait sur mon
visite ils ont sûrement écouter leurs
travaux respectifs
et du coup c'est là qu'est sorti l'album
le plus psychédéliques des beatles
piper at the gates of dawn allait
susciter de nombreuses comparaisons avec
sa john pepper en raison de leur sortie
simultanée et de leur influence sur le
hit parade britannique côté les bons
repères compositeur n'importe quel jeune
artiste se sont un peu mes piques
assiettes il chaparde des choses ici et
là ils font tout ce qu'ils en font
quelque chose de nouveau pour un
musicien aussi sensible et pointu coach
rennais il était impossible de ne pas
relever que faisait les autres pour
réfléchir à ce qu'ils pouvaient en faire
de son côté ça n'a rien de répréhensible
pour moi ça fait partie du processus de
tout grand ses sites se servait d'un
briquet zippo te faire un slide sur sa
guitare
essayez toujours inventer de nouveaux
sons pour changer de son clavier et
qu'elle épouse même faute lennon a senti
que les pink floyd était sur le point de
faire quelque chose d'important là
encore à cause de l'influencé indienne à
ce moment là il avait été voir le mari
et pendant quelques temps ils ont porté
des perles et des fleurs dans les
cheveux
ils parlent mal à pratiquer la
méditation transcendantale toutes ces
conneries m mais c'était assez de
l'acide
on avait plus rien à faire de ce côté là
ça a des limites tout ça vous est temps
qu'elle est là je n'ai rien pris que
devez vous faire pour atteindre cet état
de penser après quelques séances avec un
enseignant expérimenté
on peut vivre cette expérience ça prend
du temps après prime de lierre et
comment savez vous quand ça se produit
on commence à se détendre
dès le début on sent qu'on attend à des
gains supérieurs de bien-être on se sent
plus énergiques pour tout dire que le
travail oit coûts et de son sort de soin
et on a envie de s'y mettre minable
[Musique]
piper at the gates of dawn est reçu avec
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé et pink floyd
devient la coqueluche d'une
contre-culture florissante
[Applaudissements]
pour engager des concerts tous les soirs
on avait des groupies qui hurlaient ce
site est une vraie star
il aimait sac je crois que si
d'apprécier vraiment cette partie là du
boulot pas la célébrité
alors que nous autres ça nous mettait
assez mal à l'aise le premier album a
très bien marché
enfin le passé dans ce top of the witch
ou ici il me plaît qui était au top 10
si vous alliez les voir en concert et
jouer une paire stellar overdrive
pendant une demi-heure qu'ils
exploraient de nouveaux horizons mais il
avait aussi des chansons pop
au hit-parade garder cet équilibre
pendant un moment que ça change
[Musique]
même à ce stade précoce syd barrett
montre des signes de fragilité mentale
est il aurait joué plus à l'ufo club
parce qu'ils étaient devenus trop connus
et cède mais ils ont dit on reviendra
l'été prochain faire un petit concert
pour l'amour de la musique
en souvenir du bon vieux temps autre
homme sec sont donc venus et à un moment
s'il est passé devant moi j'ai regardé
et c'est comme si sa lumière avait été
teintes ses yeux avait l'air
complètement vide et 1 c'était deux
seraient troublant après leur premier
album piper at the gates of dawn
je me souviens de sites disant ça ne va
rien me fait rien c'était le moment où
on santé s'y glisser il était moins
intégrés ils commencé à se désintégrer
il voulait vraiment conserver son
intégrité artistique
il n'aimait pas le côté commercial de la
musique si emilie pelé a vraiment
décollé après leur passage dans 14 ils
ont fait trois apparitions pour ce
single
bien que siné refuser la troisième
montre déjà des signes de troubles
il refusait de devenir une pop star
avant même qu'il ne soit vraiment des
stars de la pop
devait enregistrer une émission de radio
à la bbc
s'il n'est pas venu je crois que c'était
un vendredi et on ne le trouvait nulle
part on l'a attendu et on a été obligé
d'annuler l'enregistrement ou alors on
l'a fait sans lui
les managers l'ont cherché partout et
quand ils l'ont trouvé le dimanche ou le
lundi suivant
ils nous ont dit il est arrivé quelque
chose acide il a dû lui arriver quelque
chose il est transformé complètement
différente
j'ai assisté à la séance quand ils ont
joué 6 ml plaît et si tu étais un autre
homme au début il n'a pas semblé me
reconnaître ils me regardaient sans me
voir comme rogers l'a dit très justement
ses yeux étaient comme des trous noirs
dans l'espace art libris
[Musique]
les anecdotes sur le comportement
erratique de sites sont nombreuses
[Musique]
j'étais dans le west end et j'ai croisé
la petite amie de sida cambridge circus
elle avait l'air paniqué elle m'a fait
signe et ses vues sida fallait dans le
caniveau cv dans l'une des petites rues
qui descendent à seven dias elle m'a dit
qu'il prenait de l' incident tous les
jours depuis une semaine et il avait
l'air complètement ailleurs
[Musique]
il était difficile de dire quand il en
avait pris au no line ccid nigel et moi
sommes partis dans un cottage au pays de
galles et on a pris du lsd et déjà à ce
moment là où pouvaient à peine
communiquer avec sid
c'était comme s'il n'était pas vraiment
là il avait un comportement très étrange
un instinct une fois il a passé toute
une soirée en équilibre sur une
bouteille pieds nus en soutenant une
poutre mon pays c'est moi qui souriaient
en se tenant comme ça tu as qu'il se
balançait d'avant en arrière par jean
paul and tan je me faisais du souci pour
sa petite amie lindsay parce qu elle
était désemparée
à ce moment là aucun de nous ne savait
comment gérer ça on essayait juste de ne
pas perdre la tête nous mêmes a fait on
n'était pas équipée pour ne serait-ce qu
essayer de les donner et couettes
alors on se disait c'est le génie
politique c'est le lsd à la cdc une
folie provoqué par la drogue
on savait pas on n'avait aucune
expérience des maladies mentales
je crois qu'il a juste glissé doucement
jusqu'à devenir complètement
incompréhensible on ne pouvait pas
l'aider aucun d'eux n'a basculé
maintenant on a tous ces termes
bipolarité schizophrénie c'est sans
doute de sa qui en souffrent et ça a
plus de grandes quantités de l'est et ça
l'a fait masculinité de la nasse t
[Musique]
en octobre 1967
pink floyd entame une tournée aux états
unis dès les premiers jours
l'état mental de sid menace de le
diminuer fortement on a fait une tournée
sur la côte ouest des états unis
arinç à ce que je crois qu'on a juste
fait trois concerts et il est très clair
qu'il était déjà parti il n'était plus
vraiment avec de demander à chaque fois
est ce que si tu vas y arriver ce soir
est-ce qu'il va monter sur scène et puis
thomas c'est arrivé je ne sais pas si
c'était un membre du groupe
il nous a dit venez voir ce que sid est
en train de faire un choix
il avait découpé des herbes les avait
mélangé à de la brillantine on y avait
fraude tout ça sur sa tête quand ils
sont montés sur scène ça a commencé à
fondre
c'était très bizarre lors d'un concert
il a désaccordé sa guitare sur scène une
autre voie il a joué une seule date ils
ont même dû faire venir un autre
guitariste pour assister soutenir le son
de signe parce que sinon
bien que leur star bat de l aile le
groupe poursuit les concerts à son
retour en angleterre
un jour on leur a proposé un concert et
ils se sont demandés on prévient si
quelqu'un a répondu que ce n'était pas
la peine c'était fait ne faisait plus
partie du lot quand je repense à la
façon dont on a traité side on ne peut
pas dire qu'on ait fait de notre mieux
comme des gens bien se demander tous
comment faire pour garder le contrôle et
pouvoir continuer maintenant c'est
difficile à dire parce qu avec le recul
on voit qu'on aurait pu agir autrement
le 6 avril 1968
le groupe confirme officiellement que si
tu ne fais plus partie de pink floyd
j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone du rwanda
qui manie les pink friday may sig ne
viendra pas est ce que tu peux appeler
david gilmour pour lui demander de
prendre sa guitare et de nous rejoindre
david faisait partie du groupe je pense
qu'il ne l'a jamais regretté
au début je ne savais pas ce que je
faisais ça devait être atroce on ne peut
pas dire que je m'éclate et honnêtement
ça a été un grand soulagement d'avoir
david en gros on avait plus est grande
de ce qui pouvait se passer
puis ensuite on s'est mis à apprendre à
composer
rogers david et moi et je crois que
c'est à ce moment là que j'ai commencé
les impros qu'une cause les morceaux
plus tardif
écrit par rogers et dave sont très
différents de ceux de sid
ils sont moins denses - fin - guy
ritchie
[Musique]
après son départ du groupe en 1968 si tu
passes le reste de l'année dans un état
précaire
[Musique]
je faisais des courses chez harrods
régime ucide je crois qu'il ne m'a pas
vu il portait un sac en papier
il a acheté des bonbons il se
nourrissait presque exclusivement
sucreries c'est la dernière fois que je
les ai vus
cette époque le départ de sid a coïncidé
avec le début d'un succès aucun leur
succès commercial était un terrible amis
l'ont déjà partager un lien presque
fraternels avec cinéma possède un mot
c'était même plus fort que ça il se
sentait responsable si cet essai très
proches étaient toujours ensemble car
depuis de nombreuses années c'était un
vrai drame pays et rogers s'est fait du
souci pendant des années pour ça et
c'est fargo souci et quand six des neuf
c1 torture est toujours vide
il est mort en 2006 d'un cancer du
pancréas
les autres ont eu le mérite de toujours
s'assurer qu'il touchait ses droits
d'auteur jusqu'à sa mort
[Musique]
ce chêne c'est triste que les gens se
souviennent de lui comme de cette sorte
de coquille vide
il était l'un des rares génies musicaux
de la période
[Musique]
et même si aujourd'hui il est très peu
exposé il reste très influent au spectre
de side nous a remonté significativement
on est beaucoup revenu à sa musique
notamment avec wish you were here
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
in flight cultive un comportement
impassible sur scène très calculé pour
que leur public se concentre uniquement
sur leur musique et développe une
extravagance technologique à la pointe
[Applaudissements]
en 1973 après huit albums dark side of
the moon fait surf et pink floyd sur une
vague de popularité telle que peu de
groupes connaissent cet album primordial
devient l'un des plus acclamés dans
l'histoire de l'industrie musicale et
restos hit parade des ventes pendant une
durée incroyable de 26 ans
l'album suivant wish you were here
connaît lui aussi un succès phénoménal
[Applaudissements]
oui je suis moi rire et sans doute
l'album le plus équilibré en terme de
musique
il a une force émotionnelle unis pour
moi il est plus fort que dark side of
the moon
[Musique]
après we show arrière l'alchimie au sein
du groupe faibli rapidement
pendant qu'on l'enregistré cet album
après l'effervescence du succès de dark
side of the moon
d'une certaine façon je sentais qu'on
était fini un saut de en tout cas en
tant que groupe pop unis comme une pente
de frère on ne l'était plus et on
n'allait pas leur devenir
[Musique]
je pense que c'est sur ce dernier album
quand on travaillait beaucoup ensemble
quand on l'a commencée on y mettait pas
tout notre coeur des désaccords sont
apparus à ce moment là c'est à cette
période que je me suis séparé de ma
première femme
je me souviens avoir une expérience
étrange jour alors qu'on déjeuner ici
dans les studios d'abbey road
je pense que je peux décrire ça comme ça
j'étais assis à table on page manger un
morceau tweets et d'un coup tout a
défilé devant moi comme si tout ce qui
m'entoure est passé à travers
l'extrémité d'intéressant c'est parti
comme ça je me suis dit une adresse je
suis en train de perdre la tête
et si la réalité change complètement
l'année 1979 marque la sortie de the
wall conçu par roger waters
ce double album ambitieux comporte une
performance spectaculaire en live ainsi
qu'un long métrage novateur the world
vient rapidement à l'incontournable
rogers waters est venu me voir il ya une
dizaine d'années il m'a fait écouter les
bandes brut de the roll et il m'a dit
que ce serait bien d'en faire un film et
un spectacle c'est donc ce qu'on a fait
on a commencé à réfléchir à des images
qu'il irait bien sûr la musique et
quelles parties on voulait illustrer
j'ai fait les dessins principaux je les
ai passées au responsable de l'animation
qui ont dessiné les mouvements
principaux étaient sûrement la plus
spectaculaire de leurs performances sur
scène tu as commencé bizarrement rogers
avait craché sur un fameux pendant un
concert il a imaginé faire des concerts
où le groupe cerise ou les de la foule
nous a amené un spectacle où le groupe
était progressivement dissimulé derrière
un énorme mur sur scène ils sont
vraiment allés jusqu'aux limites de la
performance scénique plus loin même que
les stones pink floyd était le groupe le
plus excessif est le plus énorme du
monde
c'était le show le plus énorme et le
mieux conçu qui est tourné à l'époque
maintenant on se rend compte que
techniquement c'était assez basique mais
à l'époque c'était complètement avant
gardiste sur la tournée l'équipe était
composée de 120 ou 130 personnes
s'étaient plutôt bien organisé et
heureusement parce que c'était énorme
chaque personne n'était qu'un rouage
dans cette immense machine pink floyd et
est juste devenu ce groupe monstrueux
sur le point d'imploser
il y avait un problème de cocaïne au
sein du groupe tout cas chez certains
mais c'est en général ça n'aide pas
pendant l'enregistrement de ce final cut
rogers a viré rick du groupe ce qui
était vraiment triste surtout que rick
était un homme bien et ça n'a rien
changé
c'est pas comme s'il avait manqué
d'argent pour la tournée il aurait pu
rester au bout d'un moment il a été
relégué au rang de musiciens de studio
il avait quitté le groupe il revenait et
se faisait payer comme un bassiste le
studio pour moi être engagée comme
musicien de studio par le groupe qui l'a
aidé à former c'est vraiment révoltant
[Musique]
cette angoisse existentielle de rogers
le pousser à traiter certaines personnes
très durement j'ai l'impression et je
pense que rick qui était un homme
charmant agréable et paisible
on a fait les frais il n'arrivait pas à
déterminer ce qu'avait fait eric pour le
groupe allemand se souvient de
conversation avec certains autres
membres dont je ne citerai pas les noms
qui disait qu'il l'aimé bien mais qu'il
ne le trouvais pas être responsable
enfin je pense que c'était vraiment
ressuscité
mais évidemment une fois que cette idée
est lancée de la grêle est planté tout
le monde commence à partager cet avis
embuscade
le compteur buts et puce et votre année
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au milieu des années 80 le groupe
commence à céder sa prison les rapports
se sont vraiment anthony mais encore
rogers et le reste du groupe il voyager
séparément
c'est lui seul qui a tout décidé pour le
dernier album il a été appelé the final
cut et tous les morceaux ont été écrits
par rogers et en 1995 il a quitté le
groupe
ça arrive ils ont grandi ensemble
ça a duré longtemps on ne peut pas vivre
heureux en groupe comme ça toute la vie
ça n'existe pas ça n'arrive jamais
[Musique]
je n'ai aucun pouvoir de décision dans
toute cette histoire et les droits de
tous les anciens manceaux reviennent à
une compagnie appelée pink floyd news
limited qui comporte quatre actionnaires
nick mais si david gilmour et moi on a
chacun une fois dangereux toujours
intéressé c'est le cas donc je ne m'en
occupe plus c'est une pierre d'énergie
inutile pour moi après le départ de
roger waters les membres du groupe
prennent des chemins séparés jusqu'en
1987 lorsque gilmour emerson décide de
reprendre les choses en main en
relançant le gros en sortant des albums
et en partant en tournée
la première décision était de réintégrer
rick wright comme membre du groupe à
part entière
le saccage pas leur chambre d'hôtel il
ne se cache pas derrière une armée de
gardes du corps pourrait s'en voir les
rolling stones s'approcher aussi près
des pitbulls de la presse musicale
avez vous été particulièrement fier des
concerts de l'an dernier est très fier
pour quelles raisons
les concerts ont été très bons on est
fiers de l'album qu'on a sorti juste
avant et je pense que ce spectacle est
l'un des meilleurs qu'on ait fait je ne
vois pas d'autres groupes qu'ils aient
pu démarrer en jouant devant des griffes
de hippies sous lsd et qui finissent par
jouer pour des chefs de cabinet dans les
nonistes r je me demande juste si vous
vous imaginiez prendre cette voie dans
certains domaines on a régressé faut
bien le dire on apprécie toujours le
succès et la célébrité tout ce qui
s'appliquait à nous quand on se battait
pour percer il ya une vingtaine d'années
est toujours vrai
[Musique]
vous êtes en tournée mondiale est-ce que
je vais à londres a une signification
particulière c'est toujours compliqué à
londres avec ses milliers de gens qui
veulent déplacer tout ça ça va être
génial c'est une première on dit que
c'est une salle immense mais en fait
c'est l'une des plus petites houles ans
d'anjou et tournai touche à sa fin dans
nos dernières dates sont ici pourquoi
continuez-vous encore ses blagues l'eau
pourquoi vous continuez vous
[Musique]
autour d'elle cela soulage
là il poursuit sa tournée à 100 millions
de litres une partie des tribunes qu'on
pense qu'en 1200 sièges s'est effondré
quelques minutes avant que le groupement
français gilles courteix lui être
évacués et le concert annulé les experts
de santé de sécurité examine désormais
les débris pour comprendre ce qui s'est
passé
[Musique]
il y ait des imprévus assez fréquemment
vaness à venise le concert s'est déroulé
sur une barge flottante
il mesurait 110 mètres de long sur 36
mètres de large
je crois et 3 mètres 52 c'était comme un
énorme réservoir en acier on a construit
entièrement la scène sur les dole et
tout poser sur cette barge
c'était comme une grande scène de stade
en extérieur mais puis on a déplacé
tractée par deux remorqueurs très tôt le
matin dans la brume
cette structure était la troisième plus
haute de venise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
david se tenait au milieu de la scène en
observant toute cette folie ambiante et
je lui ai dit merci d'aix est vraiment
de la folie
il m'a répondu c'est le truc le plus
ahurissant que j'ai fait de ma vie et
bob je n'arrive pas y croire
la forme ans était attendu comme le
concert le plus spectaculaire de
l'histoire du rap
deux cent mille personnes étaient
rassemblées sur la place saint marc pour
entendre pink floyd
ainsi que 100 millions de
téléspectateurs à travers le monde et le
lendemain matin a eu lieu un autre
spectacle où la place saint-marc
entièrement recouverte de déchets et
d'ordures lors du concert très peu
d'installations avait été mise en place
pour les fans et il n'y avait notamment
pas de toilettes publiques
certains spectateurs se sont débrouillés
pour grimper sur tout ce qui pouvait
leur donner un meilleur point de vue et
le résultat était inévitable au moins un
monument historique semble aussi avoir
été endommagée les vénitiens sont
furieux et dans le but de désamorcer la
crise le maire a annoncé son éventuelle
démission ainsi que celle de tout son
conseil municipal tandis que venise se
remet doucement du concert de la semaine
dernière une équipe d'architectes a
annoncé que le niveau sonore de la
musique de pink floyd aurait pu causer
des dommages permanents sur les
bâtiments de la vie si c'est le cas
venise pourrait regretter encore
longtemps la venue de pin floc
[Musique]
en 1996 pink floyd entre au hall of fame
du rock n roll américain ils reçoivent
ensuite le même honneur au royaume uni
en 2005 se fait du bien d'être apprécié
et que notre contribution ceux reconnus
dans un sens et je suis d'accord je
crois vraiment qu'on a eu une influence
on est vraiment ravis c'est un honneur
et c'est plus sympa d'être reconnu comme
ça que de regarder d'autres gens entrer
ici
entrée of fame du rock ça signifie sans
doute officiellement qu'on n'aura plus
jamais à faire des premières parties
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le 2 juillet 2005 pour la première fois
en près de 25 ans le groupe se reforme
pour une ultime représentation
[Musique]
si les pink floyd arrivent à s'accorder
sur les morceaux à jouer et je suis sûr
que les membres du g8 peuvent s'accorder
pour faire régner la paix dans le monde
c'était curieux de voir ça rogers avait
l'air ravi de revenir mais david
beaucoup moins si on voyait bien que
c'était bizarre
l'animosité ambiante était visible s'il
y avait des tensions elles ont été
intelligemment masqué pour être honnête
des jeunes suivent c'était vraiment pour
le plaisir de me retrouver sur scène
avec nick liquide sightings joie immense
tel moment où on a commencé à répéter
c'était je crois le mardi après midi
précédant le concert tout de suite pour
la succès serait facile il n'y a jamais
rien de compliqué à jouer notre musique
ensemble un moment j'ai regardé autour
de moi et il y avait des gens là et ça
personne n'aurait cru qu'il le verrait à
nouveau j'en ai eu les larmes aux yeux
de les voir pour 500 me sur 7
c'était indescriptible
[Musique]
il n'avait pas cette pression des gens
qui se demandaient ce qui faisait la
belle occasion ils étaient là pour la
bonne cause et leur réunion n'était pas
le centre d'attention
beaucoup de groupes connaissent des
tensions et de nombreuses séparations
une des raisons en lesquelles j'étais si
heureux de remonter sur scène c'était de
montrer que oui on a eu des désaccords
tadic peu importe ce sont levés sur
scène en se tenant tous par les épaules
et c'était génial
ils ont enterré la hache de guerre
c'était vraiment une bonne chose surtout
que whitera était mort peu après
[Musique]
roosevelt ça a été très triste c'est
surtout qu'il semblait être parti sans
raison valable que plus
[Musique]
j'étais sidéré quand j'ai appris la
nouvelle
c'est je me suis dis merci et merci pour
tout ce que tu étais pas je suis heureux
de t'avoir rencontré et d'avoir
travaillé avec toi tu t'es un homme
adorable
es tu nous manquera beaucoup il était un
peu le souffle de vie de pink floyd
il était très sous-estimées c'était le
moins visible mais quand on parle de
génie pour moi il en était habitée j'ai
été invité pour présenter pink floyd
olivine legend award 2009 north end
c'était trois semaines après le décès de
rick wright
david a demandé tous les gens présents
dans l'hôtel de se lever et de porter un
toast à la mémoire d'heure sur ecms est
la seule fois mais j'ai vu des gens
venir me voir pour me dire qu'il n'avait
jamais rien vu d'aussi beaux essais
good job ne voulait pas l'entendre il ne
voulait pas l'entendre lui il ne voulais
pas le croire a pu être pris pour de la
différence pas rater mais je pense
justement que la force avec laquelle il
a fait savoir qu'il ne voulait pas
l'entendre correspondait à la force avec
laquelle il en a souffert
ça l'a vraiment bouleversée et comme
pour cible par est il se retrouve
exactement dans la même situation m ce
tueur j
[Musique]
roger waters et david gilmour ont
poursuivi leur carrière en solo rejoint
l'occasion par nick mason c'est presque
comme une thérapie intérieur pour rogers
d'explorer son mois le plus profond
c'est un peu égocentrique mais en même
temps les gens peuvent se reconnaître en
lui
il s'exprime pour toute une génération
de gens comme lui je lui tire mon
chapeau parce que ça demande du talent
david gilmour est considéré comme le
visage drogue maintenant et pourtant il
a eu pas mal de succès avec ses albums
solo il a fait don d'une maison à
londres une oeuvre de charité et je
pense que l'une des raisons qui ont
poussé à le faire c'est qu'ils pensent
ne pas mériter tout cet argent qu'il
continue de gagner
il n'a pas peur on peut de se tourner
vers d'autres horizons
il a sorti un album avec docteur alex
paterson de zob quarante ans après son
premier album pink floyd reste une
inspiration pour tous les fans de rock à
travers le monde
j'aime faire trouver dans les taxis au
fin fond de pays perdu du tiers-monde et
quand on ouvre la boîte à gants on tombe
sur deux cassettes que cette plume d eux
c'est dark side of the moon et l'autre
c'est madonna par exemple si en 1967
vous m'aviez dit que 25 ans plus tard en
plein coeur de l'indonésie ou je ne sais
quoi je trouverais ses cassettes dans
une voiture je vous aurais pris pour un
fou mais c'est le cas et c'est
formidable
tout le monde connaît pink floyd si j'en
parle à ma grand-mère même elle elle en
a entendu parler
c'est fou c'est fantastique c'est génial
de rencontrer des gens qui veulent un
autographe est pas pour leurs grands
parents
mais pour l'heure la musique de pink
floyd sera encore une inspiration dans
les siècles à venir quand ils ont
parfaitement su saisir l'esprit de
toutes les époques
leur musique est sans âge profane est
magnifique
[Musique]
et
il
une
[Musique]
plus
je